the wait is finally over America cat
Tim's new book barreling into
bookshelves number two on Amazon
everywhere today it's called you can't
joke about that why everything is funny
nothing is sacred and we're all in this
together a great message cat is that the
message you want people to have yes it
is the message that I want people to
have that is why I wrote that um
it is because I think everything is
funny and if you looked at the list of
stories in this book just a list of
stories in this book you'd be like
there's no way this is a funny book but
it is a funny book and there's this idea
that the more tragic something is the
less acceptable it is to joke about it
in my experience and in a lot of the
research that I found that's in this
book The more tragic something is the
more that you need to be able to joke
about it to get through it and also to
bring people together I have to pray I
was good I have to go to Joey now
because Joey's life is
which I'm really concerned I have my
book I have my my version of this the
cat gave me and when she signed it to me
in there she said but you really should
make less leg jokes
must be them because I love it it's
that's again I mean I went through right
before I started working here I had a
very rough six months where my mom died
suddenly then my grandma died then the
man I thought I was gonna marry broke up
with me in front of my father at Coney
Island and then hung out the rest of the
day sat next to be on the ferris wheel
and that was all really tough but what
made it so much tougher is that
everybody that I talked to I felt like
they couldn't really talk to me because
they were so afraid of saying the wrong
thing so then in addition to being so
traumatized I also felt awkward and
uncomfortable and so isolated and what
got me through it was humor because when
something's really scary you joke about
it that takes away a lot of the power
absolutely you read the book
first of all so I've known you for a
long time I'm really proud of you thank
you I you can tell that you wrote every
word and you worked very hard and this
is a great moment for you so I hope you
can enjoy it and joke about it but also
enjoy it and really know that we are
super proud of you thank you and you did
a great job on it I so one of the things
you say is that laughter can be the
release that you need in order to deal
with grief and there was a there's a
part in the book where you one you talk
about a horrible situation medically
that you went through that's the first
time you've ever talked about it
publicly yes correct um chapter three
um
but there's another part where you um on
the anniversary of your mom's death I
think you posted an Instagram picture
yeah and you said and if you could just
tell people about that and how the
reaction and how you were like what are
you talking about yeah the first time
the first Mother's Day after my mom died
I was so upset everyone's supposed to
other Mother's Day pictures I stayed
quiet the second time I'd already kind
of like understood what humor could do
so I posted an Instagram picture of my
laundry basket and a bottle of tide and
I just wrote mom's dad gonna do some
laundry and it made me laugh and I felt
better but people were commenting that's
so offensive and I'm like to who did you
know her like are you upset on behalf of
this dead person that I came out of this
person's body I think maybe it affects
me a little more than you who have never
met her so these people think they're
being compassionate when they do this
and actually they're being insensitive
and they think that I'm being
insensitive for making myself feel
better because then also a lot of people
have gone through this they said that
seeing me handle that way has helped
them handle it that way and feel more
comfortable judge you know I think I
think it really does help you get
through tough stuff I mean if you do it
for a living as I did for so long
horrible horrible things you have to
laugh about it but I love your chapter
that comedy is your religion and you
talk about how you restrict Catholic yes
I was a strict Catholic you got over it
look I would love I would love nothing
more than to believe in God again and I
hope that I do at some point in my life
but at this point in my life comedy I
think really can bring people together
it can give meaning to my life it has
healing powers for me and that's what I
have right now and I really what's
missing is that there's really no
forgiveness if somebody makes the wrong
joke it's like that could be the end of
your career and there's forgiveness in
the Old Testament that goes easier than
that like Leviticus is an eye for an eye
and all like levitics Leviticus is not a
chill book it's very fire and Brimstone
so I think if we're treating jokes more
seriously than the Old Testament was
treating sins we're doing something
wrong last word Harold it's not that I'm
able to keep a sense of humor despite
everything being so awful around me it
said I'm able to handle everything being
so awful because I have a sense of humor
I would argue it's awful or good hope
everybody reads the book that's the
lesson that I take from it and from you
yes thank you congratulations
congratulations so much so her new book
is you can't joke about that you better
buy it or we're not friends anymore I
wanna Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me
a favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now